any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
but uh but the final a few things i want
to do today is just ask you questions
that i
ask all my guests who come on the into
the impossible podcast
if you can spare another couple minutes
okay okay
so the first question involves what's
called an
ethical will in hebrew it's called the
zava ah
and the notion is that um when when
great minds pass away they leave not
only their material wealth in an actual
will
but uh but an ethical will and what
prompted me is when i wrote my book
losing the nobel prize
i noted that alfred nobel had no
children he was never married
and he left all his money to this prize
and the prize had
a a ethical component that the will
the money in his will would be used to
endow a prize
that could only be given to those who
had
the greatest benefit to mankind via
their discoveries or inventions in
physics chemistry
medicine um and and so forth
and so i want to ask you uh when you
reach the biblical age
of 120 uh unless you're doing some life
extension stuff that i want to hear
about some other time
but you hit that biblical age that moses
died at 120 years old
um what do you want to be leaving behind
not only to your
biological progeny but to your
ideological progeny
in the form of an ethical will well i
think that's a simple question to answer
uh i have no heirs i have no children
and uh when i die my entire estate will
pass into my non-profit foundation the
sailor foundation
and the mission the sailor foundation is
make education free for everyone forever
so we're just giving away our our goal
would be just to give away
infinite education to the world and use
all the money to do it
for all of eternity and and obviously
the the
my ethical will is i i believe that uh
education is a good thing and the world
will be a better place
if it's a more educated world and that
all of the
all of the things that i think ale
humanity
will require education to overcome and
so
an investment in education for humanity
is
is uh an unmitigated virtue
very good okay next we're going to go
continue to go into the future
uh i know you're a huge science fiction
geek you mentioned heinlein
i know you like asimov and arthur c
clarke
but i want to call to your attention the
movie 2001
a space odyssey if you've seen that
movie michael
a long time ago so the opening scene
involves these hominids on the plains of
africa
savannah and they discovered this
monolith and they don't know what it is
and they hit it with a bone
and then later on in the course of the
movie the monolith kind of appears and
it and it's
then appearing on the moon and so it's
meant to be discovered
when humanity is placed there by some
ancient civilization
and it's meant to be uh kind of a time
capsule
that would uh that would then be only
capable of being
unlocked if you will when humanity has
enough
of the wisdom that this ancient
civilization supposedly would hope for
our intention i want to ask you a
question
uh if you had a monolith and i said it's
going to last for a billion years
what would you put on it in it what
would it be about
kind of like this voyager golden disk
that carl sagan
launched on the voyager uh satellites
i mean i i suppose you would just uh put
the sum total of
the experience of humanity to date as we
understand it
in in the most detailed form you could
and leave that
right leave leave a leave the permanent
record of humanity
what else is there to leave of interest
other than
this is the this is the human race as it
lived
up until the point when it stopped
living
this is the story i think the most
interesting uh the interesting thing
i've ever read
a non-fiction is the story of
civilization by will and ariel durand
and i think just the history of
civilization
is is fascinating and
[Music]
full of uh full of virtues so i would i
would leave
the equivalent of that to the extent
that i could
very good michael okay the last question
uh also involves arthur c clarke so i am
the co-director
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at uc san diego
and arthur clark had these wonderful
kind of pithy aphorisms
the first one being what we open every
show with which is his actual voice
you'll hear it when i send you the
the videotape link and that is uh any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic i think
i heard you say that on one of your
talks uh in the past
his second law is that for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert i
like to use that on my
colleagues in the faculty club when they
get too uh full of hubris
but his third law and that's the
namesake of this podcast
is the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and that's the name
of my podcast the into the impossible
podcast
i want to ask you what mysterious aspect
of life
might have mystified you as a 20 year
old 30 year old michael saylor
but now that you've had the courage to
venture beyond your limits into the
impossible
what advice would you give to that
former version of yourself
to benefit him for the future
i think if i was speaking to my
20-something self i would
i would probably encourage them
to study the essence of
monetary economics austrian economics
and
and what is money because i think that
um
most of us don't consider what money is
and i think
uh oftentimes like i was raised in a
family
like there's a christian trope money is
the root of all evil
right there's a large segment of our
civilization
where people say money is the root of
all evil you shouldn't want it
and and then the rest of civilization
doesn't know what it is
you know and they don't think much about
it but
actually monetary economics have
determined the rise and fall
of empire after empire after empire
and not and not if you if you don't
fully grasp it
you can work 10 times harder and still
fail
and so no amount of of expertise
and and hard work and discipline
and luck will save you uh from a lack of
understanding of
of monetary economics and the
consequences of
of of a exponentially
decaying currency so i would probably
hand myself a book on austrian economics
and say
focus upon this and understand the
implications
but i'm ashamed to say i really came
late in life to an appreciation
of how important this is better late
than never
but yeah but i spent a lot of time
focused upon other things
you could be the best business person in
the world and a genius
in every respect but if the economic
system around you collapses
it was all for naught yeah i think about
it so
it is an important principle yeah i
think about that you know if galileo was
born
a hundred years earlier you know before
the telescope was invented
would we have not you know or got our
newton
been you know born 300 years earlier uh
before you know parchment was really
even in use in the printing press would
we know their names and and that
conversely makes me think maybe there
are things we're missing out on now
because the technology hasn't been there
but i think you know the foundation of
civilization you have to have peace
and i'm hoping that the future looks
peaceful but you know i've seen i've
seen i've
seen interviews with you where you talk
about you know that you
vowed that you would never really make a
mistake that you might have made in in
your past and
and when you saw a trend like you see
nowadays that you would pounce on it and
and you even said that you know before
i think you were even late to adopt
bitcoin
uh and so it's it's refreshing to talk
to you and to get uh a glimpse
of of of the future perhaps and your
thought process and to hear your
uh very intellectually honest
perspective on on life and and
everything i hope we could do a part two
maybe maybe that will be in the in the
car be fine i'd be happy too
that'd be great thank you put it
together and i'll be there i enjoyed our
our discussion thanks for having me
me too thank you michael
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic